hello in this presentation you will
discover fine textual answer a new
function in the world from language that
appeared with the village version
elemental tree and which is about
answering your questions given the text
or collections of sticks first you would
have an overview of fine textual answer
or what it is about then you will see
some practical uses of it and then we
will talk a bit about how it is
implemented
because what is interesting is that
friend checks to answer is mostly based
on deep learning approach and deep
learning is a trendy and very promising
field of artificial intelligence and now
it's notable that the whorfin language
enables you to easily play with deep
learning methods and artificial neural
networks to build this kind of
high-level applications so what is fine
textual answer routes so it's a new tool
in the suite of in a suit of text
analysis in the world from language it's
about reading comprehension so
understanding a text with machine and
it's about natural language processing
which means that it takes inputs that
are text and that are just written in
English you don't have to care about
special formatting you can speak natural
language and the functionality is
question-answering so we are going to
give a piece of text in English and a
question also in natural language and
for chicks will answer the goal of fetch
a friend extra answer is to yield the
most probable answer in the text given
the questions so let's take this short
example we give a sentence Paris is the
capital and most populous city friends
with 2015 population of 2 million
something and how many people live in
Paris and it would give you the piece of
text but most probably answer this
question so it's seeming out two takes
cases in sort X cases is about also
extracting some kind of information in a
text for example with the same sentence
you can ask to extract all the numbers
and it will give you them but with fun
texture answer yeah in this context your
just in their ceiling one number and you
are able with with the mean of the
question to express in which number you
are interested but also find textual
answer can cope with a wide variety of
questions so to illustrate that I took
this little paragraph about the weather
forecast in some region in Russia and
asked several types of questions so you
can ask what is the temperature you can
also ask this for the time when so the
from location some numbers some distance
I asked several question then friend
extra answer is able to cope with a list
of questions then here I'm threading
over the question and the respective
answer and contextual answer is almost
alright so what is the temperature in
nature for example and it gives you this
piece of pegs here that answer this
question and the same for all the
questions for example where is the air
Kucha and it's extracting you this
Russia here ok so fine diction answer
can be procedural similar to well from
alpha which also answer your question
but actually it's a very different
technology and also the application is
different in more formal fact it's based
on the carefully created knowledgebase
the teach that is a unique stuff in the
world and here you are going to be able
to provide your piece of text where you
can find the answer so you can use any
customized source of text and for
example you could imagine that you want
to find the answer in your history or
females so you could provide the FinTech
students or your history of email and
ask your question knowing in advance
that the answer will be in your email
and friend texture and sir will find it
hopefully and now let's see the options
and the old arguments of fine textual
answer
so the
the first argument is the is the text or
list of texts the second argument is the
question and then an optional third
argument is the number of answer that
you want to have you can ask for several
possible answers or in the current
example if you ask fort walton achieve
it will just give you the two numbers
that are possible population for Paris
and you can also with the first argument
ask for some properties about the
answers to know where they come from and
to have more context for example so here
for example we are going to ask for the
probability that the answer is correct
the string which is just what we what we
already add before the position in terms
of character in the in the text and the
containing sentence with the I the
answer I lighted so if we ask this on
the current example we have to answer so
there it's a list of two lists and then
you've got the probability the string
that answers the starting and ending
character in this indices in the text
and then this is the send the containing
sentence with the answer highlighted
into it which is practical to a more
context about what is this answer about
also Sunday concerning the output
structure of fine textual answer so the
design is similar to the one of image
identify for those who know this
function so if you only ask one question
about one text find textual answer would
give you just a string but if you ask
more questions or if you use the third
and the fourth argument of fine text to
answer it will return you an array whose
rank and dimensions
depends on this dimension for the second
third and fourth argument so let's
illustrate this if I ever text and I ask
two questions and it will just return me
list with two answers okay then if I use
the third argument now to ask for each
of these two question that I asked two
answers and I will have a list of list
with first the first question the twins
us to the first question and then the
dressers to the saloons question now if
I ask a list of so this sorry this was
the same as asking just the string of
the answer it will give you the same
answer and now if for the last argument
I use a list of properties then it will
be an array with an additional rank and
so the first question will come first
with then the first answer of the first
question and then all the property is a
string the probability here and the
containing sentence ok this was for the
API of fine textual answer now let's see
some practical applications of it so as
I mentioned in the beginning you can use
several any kind of collection of text
or text that you are so here I took a
mixed example when you read you can give
a mixture of the result of text search
in in locale for example an explicit
file and Wikipedia page and you could
give also some URL and then here it's
about the US Constitution I am asking
what kind of crimes are finished and
asking for five answers and then given
all that text that contains some of them
which are not relevant for the question
like the original pieces if and picture
answer is going to filter and to give
you all these all relevant answers to
your questions then a convenient source
also tool to look for is Wikipedia
because it's refreshed knowledge shows
where everybody participates so yeah
it's an encyclopedia this is always
moving so it's convenient for fine
texture answer so for example you can
search for all the pages that talks
about the Sagrada família then with
Wikipedia data you will extract all the
all the contents of these pages so it's
all this title this title
any one of these title so we will became
a big string so I hear I don't display
the string but we can comb the worlds in
them and see that in total we have
several thousands of world in which find
the extra answer can find I can search
the answer to one of your questions for
example who build the Sagara Familia
here I ask for seven five answers and
the probabilities and their containing
sentence with the I write it's and dance
so I have the column F column enough
probability and then come the answer and
we can see that
Antoni gaudí the reader architect is
coming first and you can also use world
cloud to nicely display your answer so
what cloud is a usually natural text
processing when you want to to display
some information when you've got words
and weights associated towards then
workouts are totally appropriate and in
this case the size of the words is
representative of the probability that
the answer is correct so here is all
kind of possible answers I asked for 20
at the maximum and then under when the
aggregated probability of all this
answer Antoni gaudí we will win and is
believed in reading the answers in which
mention also that when you use Wikipedia
search you could directly feed your
question into the search and for this in
the previous search I was using the
title here looking only as the title of
the wikipedia pages but here you can
search in the content directly for your
question and then yeah the Wikipedia
self is already selects some Wikipedia
pages that can answer your question and
then find texture answer will give you
the precise answer like who found the
dough and you have here the three
members of the who that found in the bed
ok and now concerning the timing so ya
find extra answer if you give a big
collection of text it can take a
significant amount of time
but we should mention that if you have a
graphical car then it can be much faster
because Fantasia answer is based on
neural networks and the neural network
can benefit from parallel computation
from graphical cards so if you've got
the compactable GPU then you can specify
it with option target device and fine
texture answer will provide you the
answer much faster so now let's look a
bit at what's inside the texture fine
texture answer what's another hood so
fine texture answer is in two step
basically if you give a big collection
of text first fine texture and cell
width we filter them two to select
several dozens of texts of passage
paragraph that possibly answer your
question measures on statistic of words
so it's looking at the words of the
question in the passage and then in a
second step we are going to do a more
computationally expensive operation with
neural networks to precisely locate
between it paragraph the answer and
assign them some probability so
concerning this first step of fine
texture and cell filtering field
filtering a significant number of
paragraph in order to have just a few
dozens of paragraph with several
hundreds of for each we use the tf-idf
approach for tf-idf min term frequency
inverse document frequency and in this
approach you first have a big piece of
text so you have a pretty fine corpus
then you can define some feature
extractor so here I show how to do it
with the form language of tf-idf and
then in this representation each word
within the paragraph will be will
correspond to one component of the
representation and the term frequency is
the number of times there's a term occur
and it will be penalized by an inverse
document frequency which means that the
common words will have a lower weight as
equally so all the stop words we have
Kwasi a new weight and the tf-idf will
focus on the good words and then you can
compute given this principle the
similarity between for example your
question and a set of sentences or
paragraph here I used the sentences
where I have got accomplished I split it
in two sentences and then if I solve all
the sentences with a cosine distance
based on this tf-idf representation I
will see that comes first the one that
contains the word of my questions I was
asking what are their halls after where
I know zeros made of and then in the
first sentence I have got alms and made
I don't have really know Sara's is
actually my corpus was all about for a
nursery so rhinoceros physical is judged
as a common world and waiting list by
the IDF term okay and then in the second
step it's about a neural network that
given some paragraph which are typically
three hundred words long no more it will
precisely find the possible answer to
your question and assign a probability
to it so it's no electron that those
didn't that was entirely designed and
trained and deployed using the Wolfram
language know all networks family that I
highly encourage you to have a look at
and this is a graph for Flair
that's corresponds to a network so the
network you have in total 78 layers each
layer is like a function that takes as
input a tensor or a zero vector or
matrix or or a list of matrices or a
tensor of higher rank and that's also
output the tensor and among these layers
there are some nonlinearities and there
are some layers some linear array years
for example with some parameters that
are going to be learned or trained which
means that they are going to be tuned to
some database to fulfill some gold to
minimize some loss function so in these
architectures for example the brown
squares represent the layers that are
learned that contain
parameters okay
so the input of the networks are a list
of tokens of the question and the
context so token means either a word or
a position mark or any other symbol so
for example here we have this question
what color are elephants and we we have
this text the balance of a grey or white
skin and the tokens will be the list of
words and I found a grey or white skin
and the punctuation marks and there is
also another vector which indicates
which words of the questions are present
in to the which words of the text are
presenting the question in any form so
for example here the world elephant it
appears in the context and the question
so here there is a vector with three
values which indicate okay the elephant
is not present in the case insensitive
case but if we ignore the case it's
present and if we ignore the syntactical
form it's also present okay and this is
just an additional feature to cope with
out vocabulary yeah because in this kind
of models as we were going to see there
are based on a dictionary of words where
they map who asked to conserve vector
that is represent the concept of the
words but the lexicon that you see is
always limited and for example if you
use the name of a person that is not
very famous you want a rich in the
dictionary but if you ask a question on
it then maybe this word is important and
you have to indicate to find textual
answer okay if you find this word it's
important okay and then when you apply
the network to this kind of inputs and
you will have a an output Association
that will give you the probability of
the start and the end and the end
position that means for each token of
the input it will indicate you whether
it has a chance or not of being the end
and the start and there are some
activation we are going to talk about
them later so if we visualize it that's
it in the green cross means the
represent the start the ability to have
the start position here so they are
there is I probability that the start of
the answer within that gray and the high
probability of that the answer ends with
white so probably the good answer will
be gray or white in this case okay now
let's go maybe a bit a bit more into
details and see what's the architecture
of this neural network because it was a
network that was really enough tailored
for this application so it can be like
this splitting into three big steps
first it encodes the the context and the
question into some some intermediate
representation then there is a step
where we are matching the information
both so it's a two-way stuff we are
going to match which information for the
context is really run for which by a
place which piece of the question and
which information of the question is
relevant of which piece of the text and
then are going to be a decoding step to
end up with some probability that the
answer will start off and at a given
position so here in this notebook I
won't have time to explain everything
but does wonder acid can can look at it
and forget but for exam but I will
insist maybe on the word embeddings the
first step so the word I'm bearing is
mapping the words which are symbolic
inputs into vectors that represent the
concept so for example if you give some
kind this 3 3 types of words and here I
have a world embedding models that were
trained on Wikipedia and in gigawatt the
kind of language model then it will map
into a space where you can separate the
concept you see so finally this first
step here is getting the concepts behind
this word but independently for each
world whereas in the second layer here
we have a record layer where the output
at a given position will depend on all
the worlds that become before and after
so here we are going to to also
understand the semantics but in context
so to resolve the ambiguity for example
if you have an ambiguous word depending
on a context it will choose the concept
of the worlds then we have a two-way
attention mechanism when first we are
going to reinterpret the question given
the context so each word of the question
is going to throw attention at the
context and to give a new representation
and conversely the context is going to
shock the attention add the question and
in the end here we are going to have a
representation of the context that is
given the question so that is taking in
the question into account and then we
are going to have again some be
directional or a micron layers that
finally provide the probability of the
answer to be right to be at the given
location so in conclusion we have here a
new natural language processing function
that is based on state-of-the-art
neural networks there is a link to a
blog here that where you will see what
is I tell today in a form of a story and
it's important to to underline the fact
that the technology is different from
the one of Wolfram Alpha so it is a new
technology based on neural networks and
here I insist that there are a great
improvement in the neural network framer
in the Russian 11.3 that enabled us to
design this new application and I highly
encourage you to to have a look at this
framework which is incredible to to make
new kinds of application and there's
going to be more and more similar
functions in the language that are based
on deep learning for example for now in
division Berlin there is already imagine
indentify and imagery style and we are
working on many others so more and more
this more and more application like this
will be released in the future thank you